we all get feedback sometimes and so
does your app take these review
seriously they're pretty clear view into
the mind of your users when you're
developing your app you can be so close
to it that can be hard to step back and
see the forest for the trees you might
also be so in love with your app that
you ignore some of the things that don't
work so well it's an easy pit to fall
into now once you launch your app
listening to your reviews and feedback
is a perfect opportunity to iterate and
revise so you can make your app even
better than it was before use the
feedback to improve the app and make
your user happy because ratings are
incredibly important highly rated apps
generate significantly more in sales
three and four star rated apps are nine
times more successful than two and three
star apps and four and five-star rated
apps are four times more successful than
three and four star rated apps and don't
forget to respond to your users feedback
and reviews this is going to help your
users feel more engaged and it's going
to keep you connected to the most
important person the customer